Well Laura we've heard all
about current care from you and
others here at
the Rhode Island Quality Institute, but
I want to come back to you and
let's look out in the future.
What is the future of current care and
of HIE and is there anything that you
really want our students to
take away from this interview?
>> I think that HIEs have focused
historically on providing information
to physicians, hospitals, providers,
long term care and so forth.
By the time they see this,
we're going to be turning the power of
the HIE toward consumers and people.
We know from McGuinness' research that
in terms of the greatest predictors of
morbidity and mortality,
our health care system is only 10%.
We're 85% of where the money is spent
but it's only 10% of the impact.
More and more care is
migrating out of the hospital,
out of primary care doctors offices
into the community and into the home.
So, we are busy building
an opportunity for patients to
look directly into their current care
record, to upload their own information,
be it biometrics that they're wearing an
embedded to manage their blood pressure.
Or their measure their glucose or
their Fitbit, or
whatever device they're wearing.
We know that when we go to Appapalooza
events, the inventors get up and
say we have the coolest app since sliced
bread, and the greatest thing about it,
we're going to be able to send your
data directly to your doctors.
We know the doctors in the audience
are going [SOUND] I can't take
in data from every device.
We can take in data, we can organize
it and we can use direct to alert
physicians when something is going on in
the home that they need to know about.
Where on, if they act upon that,
then they can prevent an admission, they
can prevent a patient with congestive
heart failure picks up seven pounds in
two days, we'll alert your care manager.
That patient will home with
their family on Friday night and
not drowning in their
own fluids in an ED.
So I think it's that idea of beginning
to look at the quantified self,
mobile health, and
how HIEs will begin to integrate
that information into that record so
it is all one comprehensive record.
Problem with a lot of mobile
health right now is it definitely
collects your data and it sends it
up to your mobile health platform,
not integrated with anything else.
So I think it's that, and the idea that
we will use direct in the future because
while I may want my 70-year-old mother
to use the current care platform,
my guess is that she
won't be using that.
I'll want a proxy message to come to me.
And so I will want an alert from
our hospitals that tell me,
your mom just got admitted to an ED,
because my mom lives in Colorado and
I live in Massachusetts and
Rhode Island.
So, I'm going to want an alert.
>> So it sounds like any physicians
out there watching this interview and
worried about meeting the VDT
requirements of meaningful use stage
two, should just pack their bags and
move to Rhode Island.
You're going to do it for them.
>> We'd love it.
Because with our portal we do have the
view download and transmit capability.
And so we're, give the ability for
someone to get their complete
longitudinal record and
current care in the PDF form.
They can put it on a USB drive, they can
email it to their daughter, whatever.
>> Well, thank you so much.
>> My pleasure.
>> I appreciate your allowing us
to come up today, talk to you and
some of your stuff.
Thank you.
>> It's been a pleasure.